when he has said enough he has said
enough sandra that's the way it goes
well as millions of americans are set to
receive the covet 19 vaccination the u.s
government wants to be able
to access and share information on
recipients saying
it's critical in the response to the
pandemic but a federal database now
raising concerns over privacy
mark meredith is live for us in
washington mark good morning to you how
concerned
should people be well trace the
government doesn't think there's much
reason for concern but others aren't so
sure now the state and local governments
with vaccinations underway
really face a gargantuan task of trying
to track their progress
when americans go to get vaccinated they
are going to be getting a physical
vaccination card
that's going to be one key in all this
but also the state and federal officials
are going to be relying to collect
electronic data on who's being immunized
and when
the head of the american immunization
registry association tells fox news
americans can be rest assured that
material like social security
numbers private medical data from past
years
is not going to be widely collected
as these systems have been developed
we've purposely excluded a number of
features that would actually make it
more inclusive of certain conditions so
like hiv status or
or something that might make somebody a
candidate for more immunizations but we
don't want that information in the
system for those very reasons
the cdc has faced some questions though
from governors and others about the
safety of its data it's being requested
as well as whether or not that data
could eventually be used against some
people
privacy experts we checked with say it
makes sense for people to want to limit
what data
is collected and stored
i think that data
once it's out there can never come back
that's why i'm one of these people who's
really
very strongly supports collecting and
utilizing the minimum amount of data to
accomplish
a specific process and nothing more
so that's the government route but there
are still so many questions about what
travel will look like events will look
like in 2021 whether or not you'll have
to present
some sort of pass on your mobile device
to get into something like that
private companies are working on those
apps to show people proof of vaccination
but what kind of data will be stored and
is it going to be safe that's a question
that still has yet to be answered trace
a lot of unknowns but the world is
definitely changing mark meredith life
for us in d.c